more typos for Cody and moody
[Music]
in August we were pleased to officially
open pelvic drive we had a great turnout
from local residents and vintage car
enthusiasts
Rovio terraces continue to make good
progress with the river bank now looking
a lot tidier and the seating areas
starting to take shape
[Applause]
[Music]
when we developed the recovery plan for
these areas the community really clearly
told us what facilities they wanted to
have the draft reserves master plan is
effectively a blueprint that sets out
how those ideas fit into this space
developing the reserves master plan is
the last key planning and design
exercise before we get into construction
that's looking out where the activities
and features will go where the pathways
go we will have some key planting where
our stormwater management areas are one
key project is the construction of
multi-purpose sports fuels with changing
rooms toilets and parking it's also
planned to build two dedicated softball
diamonds these will help cater for the
huge growth in the sport and allow
tournaments to be hosted in their
district 11 years ago were two teams
where we're very close to 20 gives them
the ability to to have some some very
good facility to play on rather than
just a bit of dirt the plain dog park
will have areas for by small dogs and
large styles we're keeping many of the
existing trees so it'll look
well-established right from the opening
this has consistently been one of the
most requested facilities for the
regeneration areas I think there needs
to be some where feet stuffed close by
for dogs and owners to be of their
fleetly dogs off the leash
I think rubbish burns is a big thing
that a dog pack needs and some of the
dogs to be able to have a drink people
Fortin planning has gone into making
sure the reserves can be enjoyed by
everyone throughout all the new reserves
we've tried to maximize the walking and
cycling tracks the tracks will link up
to existing reserves into some of the
key activities and features we're
proposing you can find out more about
the draft reserves master plan on the
council website
[Music]
whose projects to get underway will be
the stormwater management areas and work
will start on those in the next month
we'll take a closer look at the progress
on those in the next update for more
information about the regeneration visit
any council service center or
Waimakariri govt tnz ford / regeneration
[Music]